Si están presentes aquí hoy, y estoy muy contenta de que así sea,
es porque han escuchado decir que el desarrollo sostenible
nos salvará de nosotros mismos. Sin embargo, cuando no estamos en TED
se nos dice que una agenda real de política sostenible no es viable.
Especialmente en grandes áreas urbanas como Nueva York.
Esto sucede porque los que tienen el poder de tomar decisiones,
tanto en el sector público como en el privado,
en realidad no sienten que están en peligro.
El motivo por el cual estoy aquí hoy es, en parte, por un perro:
una cachorrita abandonada que encontré bajo la lluvia en 1998,
que resultó ser una perra mucho más grande de lo que imaginé.
Cuando llegó a mi vida, estábamos luchando contra un enorme depósito de desperdicios
planificado en las orillas del East River, a pesar de que Nueva York
ya manejaba más del 40% de todo el residuo comercial de la ciudad.
Una planta de tratamiento de aguas residuales, otra de sedimentos de aguas residuales,
cuatro plantas nucleares, el centro de distribución de alimentos más grande del mundo,
y otras industrias que hacen circular a más de 60 000 camiones diésel cada semana.
El área tiene, además, la menor cantidad de parques de la ciudad.
De modo que cuando me contactaron del Departamento de Parques
para obtener un subsidio de 10 000 dólares en semillas para el desarrollo de proyectos
a la orilla del río, pensé que las intenciones eran buenas pero un tanto ingenuas.
Viví en esta área toda mi vida y no se podía ir al río por
todas esas hermosas instalaciones que he mencionado antes.
Un día, mientras corría en el parque, mi perra me condujo
hacia lo que pensé que era simplemente otro basurero ilegal.
Había malezas, pilas de basura y demás sustancias que no mencionaré aquí.
Mi perra continuó conduciéndome hasta que llegamos al río.
Supe que valía la pena salvar ese pequeño lugar olvidado,
abandonado como la perra que me había llevado allí.
Y supe que crecería hasta ser el orgulloso comienzo
de la revitalización llevada a cabo por la comunidad del nuevo sur del Bronx.
Y, como mi perra, fue una idea que creció más de lo que había imaginado.
Cosechamos mucho apoyo durante el camino.
Y el Hunts Point Riverside Park se convirtió en el primer parque de la ribera del río,
el primero que tuvo el sur del Bronx en más de 60 años.
Multiplicamos ese subsidio de 10 000 dólares en semillas por 300, y así
se convirtió en un parque de 3 millones de dólares. Y en el otoño... en realidad
voy a comprometerme con mi pareja. Muchas gracias. (Aplausos)
Ese fue él que presiona estos botones de aquí, lo hace todo el tiempo.
(Risas). (Aplausos)
Los que vivimos en comunidades de justicia ambiental
somos el canario en la mina de carbón. Sentimos los problemas en el momento.
Para los que no estén familiarizados con el término, la justicia ambiental se trata de que
ninguna comunidad debería llevar más cargas ambientales
y menos beneficios ambientales que otras.
Lamentablemente, las razas y las clases son indicadores confiables
de dónde encontrar lo bueno, como parques y árboles,
y dónde encontrar lo malo, como plantas nucleares y basureros.
Como persona negra en los EE.UU., tengo más posibilidades que un blanco
de vivir en un área donde la contaminación del aire sea un peligro para mi salud.
Tengo más posibilidades de vivir muy cerca de
una planta nuclear o química, y de hecho así es.
Estas decisiones sobre el uso de la tierra crearon condiciones hostiles que
provocan obesidad, diabetes y asma.
¿Por qué alguien saldría a caminar en un barrio tóxico?
El 27% de obesidad que tenemos es alto, incluso para este país, y genera la diabetes.
Uno de cada cuatro niños del sur del Bronx tiene asma.
La tasa de hospitalización por asma es siete veces mayor a la media nacional.
Estas consecuencias nos afectan a todos.
Y todos pagamos un precio muy alto por el desperdicio sólido,
problemas de salud relacionados con la contaminación y más detestable aun
el costo del encarcelamiento de nuestros jóvenes negros y latinos,
quienes tienen un potencial inmensurable sin explotar.
El 50% de nuestros residentes viven por debajo de la línea de pobreza.
El 25% de nosotros está desempleado. Los ciudadanos con bajos recursos
frecuentemente visitan las salas de emergencia como consultorios de atención primaria.
Esto implica un alto costo para los contribuyentes sin beneficios proporcionales.
Los pobres no solo siguen siendo pobres, sino que siguen estando enfermos.
Felizmente, hay muchas personas que estamos esforzándonos por encontrar soluciones
que no comprometan las vidas de las comunidades de bajos recursos a corto plazo
y que no nos destruyan a largo plazo.
Nadie desea eso. Es lo que tenemos en común.¿Y qué más tenemos en común?
En primer lugar, todos somos increíblemente apuestos --
(Risas) -- nos graduamos de la secundaria, la universidad, el posgrado,
viajamos a lugares interesantes, no tuvimos hijos en la adolescencia,
somos económicamente estables, nunca estuvimos en prisión, bien.
Bien. (Risas).
Pero, además, al ser una mujer negra, soy diferente a ustedes en muchos aspectos.
Vi incendiarse a casi la mitad de los edificios de mi barrio.
Mi hermano mayor, Lenny, luchó en Vietnam
y luego asesinado de un tiro a unas pocas manzanas de nuestra casa.
¡Por Dios! Crecí al frente de una casa que producía y vendía drogas.
Sí, soy una niña pobre del ghetto.
Estas son las cosas que nos diferencian.
Pero las cosas que tenemos en común me separan de las personas de mi comunidad.
Y me encuentro entre estos dos mundos,
con el amor suficiente como para pelear por la justicia.
De modo que ¿por qué las cosas fueron tan diferentes para nosotros?
A fines de la década de 1940, mi padre, un empleado del ferrocarril, hijo de esclavos,
compró una casa en el área de Hunts Point, en el sur del Bronx.
y unos años después se casó con mi madre.
Entonces, la comunidad era un barrio de blancos de clase trabajadora.
Mi padre no estaba solo.
Y a medida que otros como él buscaban su propia versión del sueño americano,
era común que los blancos se mudaran del sur del Bronx y de muchas otras ciudades del país.
Los bancos y ciertas áreas de nuestra ciudad tenían líneas rojas
y así quedaban fuera del alcance de cualquier inversión.
Muchos arrendadores creían que era más rentable quemar sus edificios
y cobrar el seguro que venderlos en esas condiciones,
a pesar de los anteriores inquilinos muertos o heridos.
Hunts Point era anteriormente una comunidad de trabajadores,
pero en ese momento los residentes se quedaron sin trabajo, y sin hogar.
A estos problemas se sumó el auge de la construcción de autopistas nacionales.
En el estado de Nueva York, Robert Moses encabezó una agresiva campaña de autopistas.
Uno de sus principales objetivos fue facilitar el camino para los residentes
de comunidades ricas que debían viajar del condado de Westchester a Manhattan.
El sur del Bronx, que queda en el medio, no tuvo opción.
Los residentes recibían un aviso con menos de un mes de anticipación
antes de la demolición de sus edificios. Se desalojaron a 600 000 personas.
La percepción común era que los proxenetas, los narcotraficantes y las prostitutas eran del Bronx.
Y si desde niño te dicen que no hay nada bueno en tu comunidad
que es mala y fea ¿cómo no va a reflejarse en uno?
Así, nuestra propiedad no valía nada, excepto que era nuestro hogar, todo lo que teníamos.
Y felizmente para mí, esa casa y el amor que tenía, más la ayuda
de mis maestros, mentores y amigos fue suficiente.
Ahora, ¿por qué es importante esta historia?
Desde una perspectiva de planificación, la degradación económica
genera la degradación ambiental, que a su vez genera la degradación social.
La falta de inversión que comenzó en la década de 1960
preparó el terreno para todas las injusticias ambientales que vendrían.
Aún hoy se usan legislaciones anticuadas sobre el uso de la tierra
para que sigan existiendo las instalaciones contaminantes en mi barrio.
¿Se tienen en cuenta estos factores cuando se decide la política del uso de la tierra?
¿Cuál es el precio de estas decisiones? ¿Quién paga?
¿Quién gana? ¿Hay algo que justifique lo que sufre la comunidad?
Esta era una "planificación", que no consideraba nuestros intereses.
Cuando nos dimos cuenta de esto, decidimos que debíamos hacer nuestra propia planificación.
El pequeño parque del que les he hablado fue la primera etapa
de un movimiento ecologista en el sur del Bronx.
Solicité un subsidio federal de 1 millón 250 mil dólares para transporte
para diseñar el plano de una explanada en la ribera del río con ciclovías.
Las mejoras físicas ayudan a informar la política pública sobre seguridad vial,
la ubicación de basureros y otras instalaciones,
que, si se hace correctamente, no compromete la calidad de vida de la comunidad.
Brindan oportunidades de ser más activos físicamente
y de desarrollo económico.
Tiendas de bicicletas, puestos de jugo...
Contamos con 20 millones de dólares para construir los proyectos de la primera fase.
Esta es Lafayette Avenue y aquí está rediseñada por los arquitectos Matthews-Nielsen.
Este circuito conectará el sur del Bronx con
más de 160 hectáreas del parque de Randall's Island.
En este momento nos separan alrededor de 7 metros de agua, pero esto cambiará.
A medida que cuidemos el medioambiente, su abundancia nos devolverá aún más.
Conducimos un proyecto que se llama Bronx Ecological Stewardship Training
que brinda capacitación en restauraciones ecológicas
para que la gente de nuestra comunidad pueda aspirar a estos trabajos bien pagados.
Poco a poco, estamos sembrando el área con trabajos de ecología,
y así la gente tendrá participación financiera y personal en el medioambiente.
La autopista Sheridan es una reliquia de la era de Robert Moses
construida de detrimento de los barrios que quedaron divididos.
Incluso en las horas pico, casi no se utiliza.
La comunidad creó un plan de transporte alternativo
que permite la eliminación de la autopista.
Ahora podemos reunir a todos los interesados
para prever cómo pueden utilizarse mejor estas 12 hectáreas y crear
parques, viviendas asequibles y desarrollo económico local.
También construimos el primer techo ecológico y fresco de Nueva York
sobre nuestras oficinas.
Los techos frescos son superficies altamente reflectantes que no absorben el calor solar
y lo transportan al edificio o a la atmósfera.
Los techos ecológicos son de tierra y plantas.
Ambos pueden usarse en lugar de materiales derivados del petróleo
que absorben el calor, contribuyen al efecto "isla de calor" y se degradan con el sol,
que luego nosotros respiramos. Estos techos además retienen el 75% del agua de lluvia
de modo que reducen la necesidad de la ciudad de pagar costosos desagües que
por lo general se encuentran en comunidades de justicia ecológica como la mía.
Y además constituyen un hábitat para nuestros pequeños amigos.
(Risas). ¡Qué guay!
Este proyecto es un trampolín para nuestro propio negocio de instalación de techos ecológicos
que generará empleo y actividad económica sostenible en el sur del Bronx.
(Risas). (Aplausos). También me encanta eso.
Sé que Chris nos pidió que no publicitemos nada aquí,
pero como tengo toda su atención: necesitamos inversores. Fin de la publicidad.
Es mejor pedir perdón que pedir permiso.
(Risas). (Aplausos).
Antes del Katrina, el sur del Bronx y la Novena Guardia de Nueva Orleans tenían
mucho en común: gran cantidad de población negra
y ambos son la cuna de la innovación cultural, piensen en el hip-hop y el jazz.
Ambas son comunidades a orillas del río que tienen industrias
y residentes que viven cerca de ellas.
En la era post Katrina, tenemos aún más cosas en común.
En el mejor de los casos somos ignorados, y en el peor, maldecidos y abusados
por agencias reguladoras negligentes, zonificación perniciosa y responsabilidad gubernamental débil.
La destrucción de la Novena Guardia y del sur del Bronx fue inevitable.
Pero hemos aprendido valiosas lecciones sobre cómo desenterrarnos.
Somos más que simples símbolos nacionales de las zonas urbanas deprimidas.
O problemas que se resuelven con vacías promesas de campaña de presidentes que van y vienen.
¿Permitiremos que la costa del Golfo de México
languidezca por una o dos décadas como el sur del Bronx?
¿O tomaremos medidas y aprenderemos del recurso propio
de activistas radicales que surgieron de la desesperación en comunidades como la mía?
No esperamos que los individuos,
las empresas o el gobierno hagan de este mundo un lugar mejor porque es lo correcto.
Esta presentación solo da cuenta de lo que he estado haciendo,
solo una pequeñísima parte. No tienen idea pero
si quieren saber les contaré después.
Pero sé que es el resultado final, o lo que se percibe de éste,
lo que motiva a las personas.
Me interesa lo que llamo el "triple resultado final"
que puede producir el desarrollo sostenible.
Desarrollos que pueden generar frutos positivos para todos:
los desarrolladores, el gobierno y la comunidad donde se realizan los proyectos.
Actualmente, eso no sucede en Nueva York.
Y estamos trabajando con un déficit en el planeamiento urbano integral.
Se destina una enorme cantidad de subsidios gubernamentales para la
construcción de hipermercados y estadios en el sur del Bronx.
Pero hay una coordinación deficiente entre las agencias de la ciudad para
tratar los efectos del aumento de tránsito, contaminación y residuos sólidos
y el impacto en el aire. Y la manera en que abordan la economía local
y el desarrollo laboral es tan pobre que ni siquiera es gracioso.
Porque además de ello, el equipo deportivo más rico del mundo está reemplazando
al estadio Yankee Stadium al destruir dos parques que la comunidad adora.
Tendremos aún menos que el estadio que he mencionado antes.
Y si bien menos del 25% de los residentes del sur del Bronx tienen automóviles
estos proyectos incluyen miles de nuevos estacionamientos
aunque carecen de importancia en términos de tránsito público masivo.
Lo que le falta al debate amplio es un análisis de la relación
costo-beneficio entre no arreglar una comunidad insalubre
cuyo medioambiente corre peligro, e implementar
cambios estructurales sostenibles.
Mi agencia está trabajando de la mano de la Universidad de Columbia y otras
para tratar estos problemas.
Pongamos las cosas en claro: yo no estoy en contra del desarrollo.
Vivimos en una ciudad, no en una reserva natural. Y he aceptado el capitalista que llevo dentro.
Y seguramente todos ustedes lo llevan también, y si no lo han aceptado deberían hacerlo.
(Risas). Entonces, no tengo ningún problema con que los desarrolladores ganen dinero.
Hay suficiente evidencia que demuestra que el desarrollo sostenible,
que no daña la comunidad puede ser un negocio millonario.
Compañeros de TED, Bill McDonough y Emery Lovins,
personas que admiro por cierto, han demostrado que esto es posible.
Sí tengo problema con los desarrollos que híperexplotan
comunidades vulnerables políticamente para obtener ganancias.
Que esto siga sucediendo es una vergüenza para todos
porque todos somos responsables del futuro que creamos.
Siempre trato de recordar que existen grandes posibilidades de aprender de visionarios de otras ciudades.
Esta es mi versión de la globalización.
Tomemos como ejemplo a Bogotá: una ciudad pobre, latina, acosada por la violencia
y el narcotráfico, una reputación no muy diferente a la del sur del Bronx.
Y sin embargo, la ciudad tuvo la suerte en los 90
de contar con un intendente influyente llamado Enrique Peñalosa.
Se fijó en la demografía.
Aunque pocos bogotanos tienen automóviles, los recursos de la ciudad estaban a su servicio.
Si eres alcalde, puedes hacer algo al respecto.
Su administración redujo las vías públicas principales de 5 carriles a 3 carriles,
se prohibió el estacionamiento en ellos, se extendieron las peatonales
y las ciclovías, se crearon plazas públicas,
y se creó uno de los sistemas de transporte público más eficiente del mundo.
Por estos brillantes esfuerzos, el alcalde casi debió enfrentar un juicio político.
Pero cuando las personas vieron que ocupaban un lugar primordial en estos asuntos
que reflejaban sus vidas diarias, sucedieron cosas increíbles.
Las personas dejaron de arrojar basura en la calle. Se redujo la delincuencia.
Porque las calles estaban vivas, llenas de personas.
Su administración se ocupó de varios problemas urbanos típicos de una sola vez
y con un presupuesto del tercer mundo.
No tenemos excusas en este país. Lo siento.
Es el resultado final. Es que su agenda de poner primero a las personas no
castigaba a los que podían tener un automóvil
sino que brindaba oportunidades para que todos los bogotanos participaran
del resurgimiento de la ciudad. Ese desarrollo no debería suceder a expensas
de la mayoría de la gente y eso es considerado una idea radical aquí en los EE.UU.
Pero el ejemplo de Bogotá tiene el poder de cambiar esa visión.
Ustedes tienen el don de la influencia.
Por eso están aquí y valoran la información que intercambiamos.
Utilicen su influencia para apoyar el cambio sostenible integral en cualquier parte.
No hablemos de ese cambio solo en TED. Estoy intentando construir una agenda política nacional
y como todos sabemos, la política es personal.
Ayúdenme a hacer verde al nuevo negro, a hacer que la sostenibilidad sea sensual.
Lo convirtamos en parte de las conversaciones en las cenas o las fiestas.
Ayúdenme a luchar por la justicia ambiental y económica.
Apoyen las inversiones que darán una ganancia final triple.
Ayúdenme a democratizar la sostenibilidad al reunir a todos en la mesa
e insistir con que un planeamiento integral puede llevarse a cabo en cualquier lugar.
¡Uy qué bien! Tengo un poco más de tiempo.
Cuando hablé con Al Gore el otro día después del desayuno,
le pregunté cómo serían incluidos los activistas de la justicia ambiental
en su nueva estrategia de marketing.
Me respondió que lo haría mediante un programa de subsidios.
Creo que no comprendió que yo no le estaba pidiendo financiamiento.
Yo le estaba haciendo una oferta. (Aplausos).
Lo que me preocupó es que esta visión de arriba hacia abajo aún está presente.
Bueno, no me malinterpreten. Sí necesitamos dinero. (Risas).
Pero necesitamos también que haya grupos en el proceso de decisiones.
Al 90% de energía que Gore nos recordó que desperdiciamos todos los días,
no le agreguemos nuestra energía, inteligencia
y experiencia que nos costó tanto adquirir. (Aplausos).
He venido desde lejos para reunirme con ustedes,
no me desperdicien. Si trabajamos juntos,
podemos convertirnos en esos grupos pequeños que crecen rápidamente
y que tienen el coraje y la audacia de creer que en realidad podemos cambiar el mundo.
Podemos haber venido a esta conferencia en etapas muy diferentes en la vida,
pero créanme, todos tenemos en común algo increíblemente poderoso:
no tenemos nada que perder y tenemos todo por ganar.
¡Ciao bellos! (Aplausos)